[Music]
hello everyone it is peri right back
here at the supper suite in Park City
talking about more movies specifically
right now one of my most anticipated of
the festival we have the filmmakers of
Wendy here early congratulations to you
both thank you so much for being here so
Ben I told you outside before that we at
last spoke in many years ago four beasts
of the southern wild still one of my
favorite movies I've watched it too many
times can't even count what have you
been up to between now and then why such
a gap between your two features I've
honestly just been making Wendy I think
I had we decided to do it at Sundance
eight years ago we got started on it a
year after that and you know the film
was designed to be an extraordinary
adventure and a circuitous path and it
proved to be every bit of that and so
everything that we did we used sort of
very much the same process as beast
working with non-professional actors
this time we went to locations that were
impossible to access we shot on an
island with an active volcano in the
volcanic regions and you know you know
we had an incredible that adventure I've
really made this film that whole time
and that Devan when she was seven years
old we shot when she was nine you know
we had to teach Kim two how to swim we
taught them how to act get them to you
know bond and and and love each other
and all that was that was the design of
the film and so I don't think I ever
knew we would I didn't know how long it
would take you know and but that wasn't
you know we had this incredible
opportunity to see through like a really
unprecedented process and and we did
just that so I'm trying to put together
the timeline here so how old are you now
Devin I'm 12 years old so you've known
Ben for quite a while yes are you super
into movies super in horror movies I'm
talking to the right person here not to
go off Wendy but what's your favorite
horror movie well that's a tough choice
between Black Swan or soft three because
I mean gore is like my everything I mean
when you see people cutting off their
arms that's just like making my day
thank you so much John Kramer we have to
do a file
blow up interview at some point and go
in on her Oh horror movie like we'll be
sitting there together and she'll be
like jump-scare and three two one she
can clock them this is except I know I'm
like freaking out right now I can't
handle it did you ever think that you
would be in a movie like this absolutely
not always dreamed about it but lucky I
might say so what was the the process
with finding her cuz I remember four
beasts it was also a pretty significant
search until you landed on your lead who
is also phenomenal so how did you guys
come together Alan working on this it
was really the same process as beasts
you know we I live in New Orleans and we
kind of have a grass root casting grass
roots casting system where we go to
schools we go to community centers and
we're really trying to get you know both
of the kids and for everybody in the
cast we're trying to get people to come
out and audition for the movie who have
never considered acting before who have
never you know had any kind of
experience and our whole process is
designed around sort of making people
feel comfortable and kind of seeing if
they have something in them that would
speak to these characters whether or not
they've ever tried it before and you
know you know something you know and
when you meet someone like Devon whose
spirit speaks to this character but also
just surprises you you know and changes
that character that that's what we're
looking for is someone that you know I I
was looking for someone to teach me who
wendy was and I met Devon and she she
did that for me
what was it about Wendy for you that
really clicked well for Wendy I really
could connect on an adventurous level
with her like Wendy is kind of someone
who me and Ben had kind of envisioned
together and then he'd give me like like
you know little ideas about like okay
maybe do this for the scene and because
you know Wendy's like this and he would
you know help write the script to where
it you know fit my personality but I
feel like Wendy for me is really like
curious and adventurous and really
courageous and I can kind of connect on
that on a personal level because my
Wendy is II are you into acting now do
you want to be in a CONUS yes I mean
whip me up and put me in a horror movie
what were you saying you wanted to be
when you grew up before you got this
opportunity well I do a lot of different
things but I've always liked singing
dancing and contortion contortion yeah
oh my god why I want to be holy so bad I
feel like you need to be like the
demonic presence there yes sir like
child possession horror movie out there
that needs to catch you now we're gonna
reconnect one day and I'm gonna
interview you for your horror movie so
for everybody out there who is thinking
I've seen enough of the Peter Pan story
what does this movie do for them that
they haven't gotten elsewhere um well
this you know we sort of begin with the
kind of the characters and art and the
frame work of Peter Pan but the story
goes in places that Peter Pan never goes
and and it's it's really about different
things you know we want to make a film
that confronts growing up with like hope
and bravery and sort of takes that on
from a you know it's not it's it's not
it's all kids but it's but it's really
for anybody that sort of has gone
through this sort of tragedy that is
losing your childhood and losing these
sort of you know it's about sort of
taking on aging and trying to keep who
you are and then what you believed in
what you dreamed as a kid and so it's
it's about those things and also you
know our Wendy you know when we went
back to Peter Pan it was like every
Wendy ever before you know she Peter
Pan's always been a story that just
teaches you that adventures for little
boys and girls stay home fix their
clothes take care of the Lost Boys
hideout and we wanted to wipe that Wendy
off the face of the earth and bring a
new one that's full of strength power
agency heart love you know she brings
love to Neverland in a way that and
family the sense of family that in ways
that has never existed in a myth before
and you know I hope it I hope it changes
the story forever I'm so excited I'm so
happy for you guys again congratulations
I can't wait to see the movie soon Wendy
keep an eye out for it thank you so much
for your time today thanks to everybody
out there
watching this interview from the supper
suite in Park City thanks to Kia
Telluride like and share this video and
stay tuned for more interviews from the
festival